You need a doctor I am a doctor
i should have died years ago
people all over the world
have my disease from here
to find a cure we have to push the boundaries
take the risks if you're gonna run do it now
are strange dr michael morbius you've been
missing for two months when you're a stranger
then you were found on a container
ship that washed up off a long island
when you're alone
what did you do to yourself doctor i wish i knew
i went from dying to being
more alive than ever it worked
not exactly i have increased strength and speed
and some form of bat radar what else can i do
there are limits there has to be there's something
inside of you who wants to hunt and consume blood
we haven't had anything this good
since that thing in san francisco
the other half wants to control you hey
dr mike you and i should stay in touch
i'd do anything to save a life but
i don't know what i'm capable of
you save lives you don't take them
are you here to heal the world
or to destroy it
who the hell are you matt i am i know i'm just
kidding it's dr michael morvious at your service
Welcome back everyone this will be my new morbius
trailer video there's a whole bunch of easter eggs
here for a bunch of different spider-man
franchises tobey maguire spider-man andrew
garfield spider-man because of the oscorp logo and
spider-man no way home as well as venom let there
be carnage so we'll break it all down if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos obviously we have a lot of
spider-man no way home stuff coming up really soon
too sort of explaining how they're all bringing
this together although if you've seen venom let
there be carnage it kind of explains how the earth
that morbius comes from now pretty much confirmed
to be the same earth that venom comes from
connects to spider-man no way home in the marvel
mcu multiverse but it is crazy here we have him
referring to himself as venom like he says i am
venom literally in the trailer you have the andrew
garfield amazing spider-man oscorp logo the same
tobey mcguire daily bugle logo but the murder plot
points from tom holland's spider-man no way home
it's almost like the sony and the marvel people
have turned into the wandavision meme trying
to connect all these dots i already talked about
all the easter eggs here but the extra easter eggs
they include on this version of the daily bugle
with the logo from the tobey maguire spider-man
movies are rhino and black cat easter eggs like is
the black cat going to show up during this movie
is the rhino going to show up during this movie
sony is developing a spin-off movie for the black
cat character i don't know when we're going to
see that but i believe that's what those easter
eggs are meant to tease as for rhino i have no
idea what they're going to do with that character
or which version it would be because the last time
we saw the rhino it was really really silly i have
a hard time believing that they would bring that
back unless they do a slightly different version
and now because of what we saw with all the
crossover easter eggs in spider-man no way
home venom let the be carnage post-credits scene
the idea with the way they're using the multiverse
even though it's still kind of confusing with this
tobey maguire spider-man logo in the tom hall and
spider-man murder plot points it makes a little
more sense the morbius movie is just taking place
on an alternate earth from mcu tom hall and
spider-man the whole thing with michael keaton's
vulture he was in prison in the new york city
area at the end of spider-man homecoming so i
believe that's the connection they're trying to
make during this film like morbius gets hauled
into prison in the new york city area and he
winds up crossing paths with the vulture who's
wearing the same white prison jumpsuit that he
did during spider-man homecoming who himself talks
about putting a crew together just teasing future
sinister six stuff and then busting out a prison
i know a lot of people are wondering who the sixth
member of the sinister six in spider-man no way
home is going to be because we have five confirmed
members from the multiverse right now i'm assuming
that vulture is probably the best candidate for
that six member but i don't know if he's actually
in the movie they might just reference him because
six extra villain characters is a lot to put in a
single movie they start with morbius going to find
the bad dna that winds up giving him his powers
so the whole idea is that morbius is called the
living vampire in the comics because he's not
undead he doesn't get his powers by being bit
by another vampire like dracula or by being bit
by a vampire bat he winds up combining special
bat dna with electroshock therapy and that gives
him his power so he doesn't die to get his powers
that's why he's not undead it is also why he can
walk around during the day they're playing him
like an anti-hero just like he is in the comics
just like they did during the venom in venom let
there be carnage movies with the venom character
in typical fashion like you'd expect him to do
jay jonah jameson on any earth in any universe
paints them as monsters the same way he does
with spider-man but they're actually trying
to help people and do good things we haven't
had anything this good since that thing in
san francisco even though during the trailer
they talk about the event that happened in
san francisco that's basically the events of
venomolothebe carnage that they're referencing
the morbius movie mostly takes place
in and around the new york city area
that's why you see the oscorp building from the
andrew garfield amazing spider-man movies because
oscorp's headquarters is in new york city the
horizon logo that you see on the highrises too
that's the biotech company where he works where
he's developing this cure like he does not work
for oscorp himself oscorp figures in i believe
through tyrese's character the weaponry and the
technology that you see him using there to try
and catch morbius he is a comic book character the
character that tyrese is playing i believe that
tech comes from oscorp and that's the connection
adria aronja that you see here is playing martine
bancroft his love interest from the comics
most of you probably recognize the music track
that they're using during this trailer it's the
doors people are strange the whole plot point with
him on the boat killing all the sailors happens
right after he gets his powers in the comics
it's a slightly different type of boat in the
comics but it's the same basic concept he's
out of the ocean when he gets his powers and
loses control and winds up killing a bunch of
people before he figures out what's going on
like a regular vampire he does need to drink blood
in order to survive but he doesn't possess any of
the regular weaknesses that vampires have like
garlic sunlight crosses holy water anything like
that he is sensitive to light like it will give
him a bad sunburn which is why you see him walking
around in daylight with his hood on but it won't
kill him like it would kill a traditional vampire
so if you remember 84 years ago when they released
the last trailer for this they didn't have nearly
as many special effects visual effects done so
they spend a lot more time showing his actual
transformation when he's activating his powers
like his face transforms into the vampire form
also the way they visualize him flying and using
his sonar abilities it actually looks pretty legit
even though obviously there was a lot of special
effects during the venom let there be carnage
movie because of the symbiotes this trailer makes
it seem like the morbius movie is more special
effects heavy than venomouth to be carnage even
though we were supposed to see this movie before
we saw venom let them be carnage i think the
reason why they bumped this further out is because
they wanted venom let there be carnage to come out
so close to spider-man no way home because of the
venom let there be carnage post-credits scene
careful for spoilers if you have not seen that
during that post-credits scene he winds up getting
transported to the mcu earth where he sees a
broadcast of j jonah jameson from the mcu yelling
about tom holland spider-man with him on screen
like with his mask off so you see that it's tom
hall and spider-man we'll see if something similar
winds up happening to the morbius character but i
have a feeling the connection to spider-man no way
home the tom hall and spider-man movies will just
be through the michael keaton vulture character
who says we should keep in touch i believe that'll
be their connection to sinister six stuff in the
future even though morbius himself will not be
a sinister 6 character we see tyrese's character
interrogating him about what happened on the
boat like they found him after a couple of
days all these dead sailors tyrese is playing
simon stroud from the morbius comics he was a
cia agent and an nypd detective who just hunted
down morbius i think the way tyrese was trying
to hype his character up he would continue on
in morbius sequels the same way that a lot of
the venom let them be carnage characters came
back from the first movie i also love the way
the venom character just in general has become
shorthand in the world that this takes place in
because he stops the mugger literally saying
venom's catchphrase i am venom before joking
and taking it back saying no no michael morby is
at your service like i said the way that sony is
using all these different easter eggs from the
different spider-man movies tom holland tomi
maguire andrew garfield is just like the wandavision meme of just everything going crazy
complicated even further because we know the
oscorp logo is from the amazing spider-man movies
but they're using willem dafoe's green goblin
from the tobey maguire spider-man movies during
spider-man no way home like does this mean we're
also going to get the other version of norman
osborne at some point during all these movies
when he's talking about his limitations about
how he needs to drink human blood the way he talks
about the darkness inside him that wants to hunt
and feed is them just trying to connect him with
the venom character like the venom symbiote wants
to hunt and feed literally eat people's brains
there were a lot of theories early on about who
jared harris was playing during this i believe
he's just playing one of his colleagues and
long time friends that winds up dying during
his origin story in the early morbius comics
i don't think he's playing like a really really
huge sinister six character or a secret character
or anything like that matt smith is playing loxias
crown he's probably going to be the main villain
of the movie he's one of the big villains from
the morbius comics who also turns into a similar
type of vampire as morbius i believe the plot of
this movie is him winding up getting his powers
in matt smith's loki's crown character also a
scientist trying to use that to nefarious ends
trying to give himself powers than just going
crazy so i would say this movie shares more
in common with venom let there be carnage than it
does the first venom movie like you have a villain
who gains the same type of powers that the hero
has and then tries to go nuts another connection
to the tom hall and spider-man movies they have
a very similar stairwell scene where he's flying
up the stairwell using his powers the same way
that vulture if you remember from way back in
spider-man homecoming came down the stairway even
though technically it's a different building the
way they film it makes it seem similar to that
vulture scene it's from a hotel that's very common
that shows up in a bunch of movies because of its
unique architecture that's in the atlanta area in
a lot of these movies film in atlanta which is
why it shows up in a lot of movies but if you
spotted any other big easter eggs or connections
to the other spider-man movies tobey mcguire andrew
garfield's amazing spider-man movies tom hollands
spider-man no way home just write them below in
the comments even venom let there be carnage
the trailer says the movie is still scheduled
to come out in january so we won't have to wait
that long after spider-man no way home to just
find out exactly what's going on and how they're
connecting this to everything we'll get that next
spider-man no way home trailer in the next couple
of weeks we're also going to have disney plus
day with a whole bunch of trailers for the marvel
disney plus series as well as the star wars disney
plus series so it's going to be like trailer
city during november and because the eternals
movie is coming out this week my full eternals
post credit scene and easter eggs and breakdown
videos for that movie will post later this week
so make sure to go see that movie when you have
a chance will you wait for everything click here
for my video on that first look at green goblin
in spider-man no way home and click here for my
venom let to be carnage post credit scene video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!